[Applause]
[Music]
I've been with NC for three years now I
want to say three and a half years and
it's been incredible to be working on
like a full-time basis with a company
who's doing something that I want to do
I think online media is been around for
a while but it's like a relatively new
thing and like the performance aspect
for actors and it's so cool so it kind
of being something that like now
everyone's like everyone wants to be a
part of it's really fun and it's a good
group of people and the fact that it sit
around for ten years is crazy because
it's like that was really when it first
started with ten years ago like that's
right when it if you've been doing it
for ten years you started right at the
beginning I think I'm so so neat and
this shows us the great products it's
been around and how fast the whole time
and it's just a great group of people
and I love them I started on working
with ten off from in 2012 on demo reel
and starting on that life it was kind of
it honestly was kind of like a dream
come true so in a moment like I was
actually being involved in a project
that was being you know publicized and
it was really exciting and seeing demo
reels you know you can't leave it kind
of broke my heart I was like sighs well
damn it alright that was my 15 minutes
of fame you know I got to get used to
the industry you know things like this
will happen
I just been watching like thing but God
ended up calling like like two weeks
later and hey I'm thinking about
bringing back you know we're going to
sell the critic in an expense money you
know come on and try out this new format
I got going you know you're welcome to
this out but yeah sure consented
shifting like you know it come back with
like a vengeance you've really been a
lot of fun and it's really changed like
my course of direction as far as like an
actor and filmmaker and
is been hella variety I am excited to
see where it goes next is a lot of fun
and having a lot of fun well it was it
started out in Doug's bedroom in our
house and it was really really sort of
neat because he would film it and then
he'd call us and say what do you think
of this and Doug's mother and I would
sit there and we say this is really
grateful you got to change like just one
little thing like this it'll even be
better and he was very good and
listening to our comments and he would
do it and then he moved away from the
house and that's when it went downhill
no one ever heard again it's been
incredible yeah I've been with the
company very early on I shot a lot of
stuff for like the behind the scenes and
the brawl and stuff like that and would
you yeah some behind the scenes kind of
camera works and stuff like that and
eventually instead of doing the
Photoshop stuff but it really was until
we open the studio and then they asked
me to come in and be the art director
basically hidden except and props and
stuff like that that yeah it was like
the opportunity of a lifetime you know
I still have to pinch myself every day
that this is what I get to do for living
I come into work and I get to play with
you know cool stuff all day um a fever
dream I never wake up from and I can't
believe I'm still here
there's really no words I mean I can try
but if they wouldn't match them it's one
of those that you do it as a hobby you
don't think it'll become a job but you
kind of hope you know but even if it
doesn't you're kind of glad you did
because you're doing what you love and
so few people get to do what they love
for a living and the fact that I can is
just so amazing and I can never be more
thankful I mean I can try as hard as I
can but it will never match it I mean it
just really changed my life it changed
Who I am
the people at watch it change who I am
and all these cliches about oh the
people they really are everything the
fans they mean the world you have a
cliches but they're really right because
those are the things you want to say you
really would be nothing without these
people and when they tell you and they
say they help you through stuff and
everything I mean that that's the world
that's like theirs they're still nowhere
that's the closest I can come talk
interaction with fans has been
incredible I think going to conventions
is one of my favorite things it's like
the highlights of my year you just get
like flooded with such kind words and
just so much positivity and love and
it's such a neat thing to feel that with
something that you're actively involved
in like really exciting it is fun to do
this it is absolutely great to work with
our crew who has been relatively stable
here for about the last four or five
years and every other Tuesday when we
shoot it's neat to come in and see what
we're going to do even though we get the
scripts on Thursday you know I never
read them so we come in and we see what
we're actually going to shoot but the
most fun part of the whole thing is in
building sets were doing music costumes
props whatever I get to play with my
fists again
yeah I'm still always shocked that
people know who I am if I you know go to
a convention or something like that but
it's always yes a lot of time to
interact with
Santu stuff like that I love seeing
people who see my awesome bills or
something or they say that they made
something that I put it on my bill the
shows or characters I played on the
entry here something like that they
really love for whatever is always cool
and fun to beautiful people and talk to
people so yeah I would look forward to a
convention for self-confessed the
conventions are the most fun because
it's really fun meeting fans like face
to face and it's I think the best thing
is this when we come up were just like
yeah I was going through a hard time and
like your guys's comedy got me through
it and that's always like the best for
us because you know like we're human I
think right and comedy like gets us
through a lot of hard things so it's
good to know them the same way we watch
other people's work and it's like yeah I
got me through a rough time that like we
can have that effect on people
so it's I mean it's not the only reason
we do it because it's also a job but
it's like the really awesome bonus like
we always just love hearing that the
fans are wonderful the people I work
with are wonderful Studios wonderful and
my boss is wonderful my family's
wonderful I'm in a wonderful place and I
have a lot wonderful people to thank for
that
you
[Music]